eliza's coming into play first going up
against cruz master raven yeah i saw the
smash bracket that crew's uh early wins
were with master raven according to the
according to the bracket and you know me
i am like i'm again remain but i love me
some master raven man i love her combos
i love her the way she plays i think
she's one of the most fun characters
playing tekken but also very difficult
right i don't i think it's hard to play
her in tournaments so when you see
actual real master raven just like a
real kazuya player right it's like you
could tell you can tell fine all right
here we go game number one though
fishing with the course of the full one
i love that move for raven and there's a
lot of moves i really like from master
raven as well i think she kind of falls
in that same same problem that like fang
has early on where it's like too many
good moves
but it's like she has a lot of moves
that like they're good but they're all
kind of all sorts of tricky you know
right and finding those different
reasons and different purposes for it is
gonna make a big difference but right
there magic four starting it off for a
bell
[Music]
immediately in the rear oh my god
instant air dive kicking that jab is
going to link off of that
nice job
paying close attention there oh nice
punish too
he's been kind of fishing with that a
lot dark wave one having many active
frames runs right into it
the extension after the back four the
squiggly leg
oh the down jab man that is one thing
that bill is very good at just kind of
recognizing when the opponent wants to
attack but nice
that's one plus two now this time the
fake out into the low
saw the tutu was whipping and then
caught the rear so it's not gonna be a
screw so he kind of wasted the meter
there lucky break for crew plus frames
after the dive kick low parries the down
jab
let me get to the wall here i don't
think it's a little bit too far
nice perfect punish you know that low is
minus 14 but eliza is one of the few
characters in the game that does have a
14 frame launch
that's one of those that does a lot look
at the damage
all right crew though got the wall
positioning
oh he tried to go for one throw
it's a special cancelable low so a lot
of times you can't get a punish on
unless you low period
and more often that you just have to
assume that it's safe
like it's a regular like the first hit
of a of a string
especially eliza because she has her
fireball ex1 and the dive kicks too
the crew finding some hits here oh man
about so good with that magic four
getting the extension with the one extra
meter trying to get the wall
wow
i don't even think what hit
was supposed to launch or anything like
that i think it's just crew i might have
thought that it was gonna hit right he
saw that the whiff happened and that's
the one thing
like two things right there right low
profile obviously eliza that move does
you know reduce our hurt box pretty low
and master raven's race drive kind of
has a high hitbox so it's like it's just
a combination of two great moves
colliding and not not reacting the way
the master raven player wanted it to
though yeah that's always been a very
popular thing with uh old school ravens
443 right it never had the best hitbox
and uh it kind of carried over to the
race drive too so see that happened
there was a
pretty common sight i think for
i don't know if abell did that like
super big brain with the downfall on
purpose get the rage drive out of the
way because that sounds crazy to me but
then the way that it worked out it just
it is i mean the belt does seem pretty
comfortable in the match but he seems to
know the punishes right he seems to know
okay you know after a certain strain
should stay blocking because i know that
this is a launcher counter at launch if
i do anything crazy right so i think he
really it seems like he's definitely
comfortable with the match simply with
crew honestly though i think cruz you
know he feels comfortable with the match
too but he just hasn't been able to get
these big hits especially with the
master raven too with wall stages you
get one hit carried to the wall that's a
lot of damage that other characters
can't really achieve like her so
yeah that's the most fun part but man
they were going into the infinite stage
so you know uh master raven actually
infinite stage damage too she does great
and she she doesn't have to
actually readjust her combos or
freestyle a little bit to adjust for the
walls fixing now she could just go for
full combo and then she has the
unskilled grounded at the end too man
that is beautiful that is my background
whenever we commented i see fc i love
those blue and purples man
but you see here crew i think he's
taking it to the infinite stage trying
to outplay our bell but also you know
probably utilizing the fact that about
can't have these walls now to put the
pressure on so if crew's gonna win this
he's gonna have to win this straight off
of you know hard tech and infinite real
tanking
wow and that's the generic throw gonna
get the meter off of that as well
i saw her her radio throws the only
throw i've seen hit the most
hey yeah
no other characters strange right i
don't know what it
is it's that one throw that i've seen
the most of out of any other throw round
yeah that's the only one for eliza that
builds meter for her too so dang the
down four three and tire
downpours is such a good move at the
start nice blocks whilst anyone's gonna
get the launch you have the whole thing
all right go to the staple
oh these standing four fours from about
have all been hitting though luckily
that wasn't counter hit but dude it
seems like a normal it launches the way
of bell's using it my goodness back one
two just threading the needle
you saw the little back dash saw crew
whiffing and immediately just went for
the counter hit there got the launch a
bell now oh so good that should be bad
there
just kind of trying to press the offense
there just trying to force it the bell
had it scattered with the jump back the
inside kick and that's the best part
about eliza right that makes her jump
extra scary is that other than like
akuma and kate
her jump back she could still come in
with the ex yeah
i mean that's the one thing you always
have you got to treat it like a back
dash it's like all right she jump back
you got to kind of you know be patient
because you know that diving can come at
any time but nice crew trying to get
this around here just a little bit out
oh oh
i think three count or
four kicks in the car i know right three
more dive kicks afterwards oh
just missed nine just this time i think
you walked a little too early on that
one yeah the tech ended up just being
like oh perfect the tech trap ended up
trapping yourself right
darkly pressure here just trying to keep
them out and then you see the dark wave
ones come into play
oh the counter here
72 and burns the meter for the extra
damage look at the damage
yeah i'm out with the fireballs now it's
just
dorsetto i think i think he was saying
eventually he's just like trying to
punish me with me trying to punish me
with me
but then the dark way one is just this
force field it's like a sonic's boom
it's an aegis reflector yeah
so good man i mean that was so smart